hello everybody I'm John Luke and I'm
joined by mass Spinelli and this is our
video review for Devil May Cry 5
you take enough
[Music]
all right kick some ass all right so you
reviewed the game to give it a 9/10
which is a superb so you liked it a lot
let's start off with what is Devil May
Cry 5 well double May Cry 5 is the
latest sequel and the long-running
done.we Cry franchise it's a big deal
since it's been 10 years since its
predecessor so to speak
there was a reboot in between but this
is sort of the new sequel that fans have
been sort of yearning for and in terms
of just like what the game actually is
and how it plays it's the character
action game of sorts really focused on
like stylish combat with it with that
with mechanics that are like near
fighting game like in their intricacy
and it's a lot of fun well yeah
so the combat is sort of the big selling
point for definitely crying always yeah
and this one's unique in that it has
three characters this time around I
never kind of they doubled with two
characters in four but now they got
three how do you feel like that pans out
this time around it pens out really well
yeah it's very meticulous about its
pacing you think that three characters
would put too much of a scope on a to
expansive scope on things but they
introduce each character who has very
unique play styles in a way that makes a
lot of logical sense you started out as
Nero who is a very accessible kind of
character that of interesting mechanics
that are easy to wrap your head around
and then you have a character like V
who's this ranged fighter who kind of
demands kind of brings in more of the
complexities of like how do you manage
the space that you inhabit in these
games and then you have Dante who's like
hey you know all those combos you can do
with Nero and V well you can do even
more of them and you have so much
freedom to be as creative and expressive
as possible with him so start with Nero
what is what is Nero bringing that is
new from this time around well he has
these things that are called devil
breakers they're like essentially
prosthetic arms that that he has an
access to a lot of different ones and
they have different different abilities
which really expands his options in a
fight makes him very interesting because
he's got these very minimal
kind of sort of like what mid-set just
as a sword and a gun which is like you
know that's classic that my cry but it
turns just the amount of moves you can
do it's very little but with the devil
breakers there's a lot of different
things you can do that said it's a
little bit more complicated complicated
than that because you can't just like
seamlessly switch between them be like
oh I can use this ability and this
ability when you start a mission nearer
has like you can equip a loadout of
double breaker arms sure you can use one
ability but if you want to switch to the
next one you have to expend it you
actually have to discard it which kind
of allow it basically has to blow up and
then you switch into the next one
yeah this kind of seems like a bit of an
arbitrary rule at first because luckily
Walker and our switch between my arms
right if you could just take them off
but mechanically what it brings to the
table it's very engaging it's very it's
intriguing because it introduces a kind
of thrilling spontaneity to combat but
it's still like there's there's a sense
of improvisation there because you're
sure you can be doing a combo and you
don't like a lot of cool like combo
strings with this one arm and it might
be efficient but then you see the next
one down line you're like well what if I
wanted to use my rocket arm and ride it
around my skateboard you know I could
wanted to do that that would you know
not only with that enhance your stock
because you know Democrat ranking system
keep that like great grade you on your
diversity combo so like you know you
might want to kind of make that decision
and at the same time even using don't
records can be like there's all high
consequence to it because if you get hit
while you're using it it'll break sure
you can switch you can break it and
switch it but it can also break if an
enemy hits you and so like there's just
this push and pull of like you know
don't want to be creative or do I want
to be like safe like how you just you're
just thinking about this is this
interesting balance between creativity
and like high-concept I con secuence
like tactics that just makes neros very
basic playstyle a whole lot of fun and
very exciting
after you played Nero though you do get
access to V who is as I mentioned you
think he's arranged fighter but that's
because he's got these like these two
like familiars like this sick Panther
who can whose basic humans as your melee
attack and then this like wisecracking
Griffon bird demonic bird thing that's
essentially your guns so this is
interesting for Delma crime because you
know Don't Cry is always about being
about like very being directly
confrontational just actively like
hitting dudes and then like thinking
about like spacing and dodging a little
bit later after that you know but with V
you're always you're actively engaged
with like you know commanding your your
familiars to do attacks and to do like
you know typical like air combo like you
can launch enemies in the air but your V
himself is like hanging back you're you
you you actually are kind of a little
bit away from the action which provides
an interesting dynamic because you know
you're more you're thinking more about
spacing you're thinking more about how
enemies are sort of approaching as
you're you know doing combos from afar
because like think because the whole
thing is like you maybe like whopping on
a dude from a range but these other
dudes are like what's he doing I'm gonna
try to poach him and try to hit him
right and so you're just like it's all
about like environment of environmental
sort of space and spatial awareness with
him not to say that like not the
characters other carriers don't do that
but there's a restraint to be that is
just so refreshing he's where Democrat
five really really expressed itself with
a lot of new ideas because there's just
something about holding back as opposed
to the really interface tactics of the
other characters that is just different
and like but at the same time it teaches
you like how to do that because that's
still important part with every other
character but you're doing it way more
as V that's it there's also an
interesting layer that I forgot to
mention with these that he actually you
know you can be like hurting these
enemies but the his familiars can't kill
enemies themselves you he actually has
to inflict the final blow and this
happens like after you hit an enemy
enough their reticle will turn orange
then you just users came to deliver like
a like a killing blow
which is really rewarding it feels
awesome if you want to do that like he's
a ridiculous edge lord character who
like he has his book that we're citing
you can recite poetry to like charge his
bevel gauge thing to summon another from
big familiar who's like his devil
trigger like attack do you the familiar
does law mechanics there but the very
core of it is just very refreshing very
different and like yeah as I said like
it really proves that Dolman cry v still
has some cool stuff to do hmm despite it
being like 10 years since like the last
one well yeah right so V is sort of like
the the new character with a lot of new
mechanics and then finally you have
Dante who sort of Li like old faithful
yeah good old faithful uh he's just all
about combo creativity because he has
like four different fighting styles you
can seamlessly switch between they have
each different abilities on top of being
able to equip for guns and for melee
weapons and you could just like seems to
switch between them at will
he's really where the training wheels
kind of get taken off like you learned a
lot about how like to do just do kind of
combos with Nero and be kind of like
diligent about them you learned about
spacing with V but with Dante it's like
you learn those things now just here it
is take this buffet of like cool attacks
and just try to look as freakin badass
as possible I love I absolutely love him
he's actually the the high point for the
combat system to me because you know he
you know he basically owes you to
express the sense of like individuality
to you know in every attack you do and
once you get to a certain point where
you're like just like what is it you
just like rushed you do a stinger
towards the to an enemy then you switch
to your your melee weapon you're like
your fists weapons and then you start
doing you breakdance fight on them on
the ground and then you equip your sick
motorcycle chainsaw and then launch of
up in the air and then like what is it
like switch the gunslinger style and
just start raining hell from above with
like your pistols it's just you just
you're just doing so many things and it
gets to a point where like you
you're so like invested you're so into
that combat you're so you feeling so
empowered and you get into such a rhythm
that you're
even thinking after a while he's making
these decisions as if it's just natural
but it's just amazing he's possible
sorry I cannot reinforce that enough no
your enthusiasm is like infectious I
mean would you say that it's out of all
the games in the series do you think
this is maybe the best combat yes
absolutely no yes sorry there is a pause
there cuz I was like are you gonna say
more because I'm gonna say yes yes no
this is like the best that Dell make
high five our Democrat has been in terms
of its combat because it just has an
abundance of new ideas but also just
smart and elegant execution of the past
mechanics as well that makes them far
better than they've ever been so the
other aspect of course is the story this
is the continuation of these characters
that we haven't seen for you know 10
years at this point it's also kind of
trying to be a conclusion to sort of
like the storyline in some ways how do
you like the story pans out
that's x'p well it's by no means like a
big character study evolve its
protagonist and stuff there's not a lot
of crazy depth in that way but that said
it does have like fun and interesting
new ideas in terms of just like the way
that it structures itself so the big
thing here is that there is it's kind of
a guy nonlinear story where like cuz you
as I said there's three characters but
you're kind of switching between them
throughout the game which really brings
a refreshing variety to the events more
so than past games were like you're just
like you know each each mission kind of
brings something different to the story
where you're like just trying to like
I'll keep trying to assemble like what
what's going on here like what are they
doing were they up to you which is
really cool like I just like Democrat
has never really been that ambitious
with its story it's like it's just been
very like you know sequential but this
like like the game makes the story makes
a huge point to just like this is what
this is the time that's passed the game
is set within the duration of a day
which is like I don't like it's very
compelling it's very intriguing to see
element cry try to tell a story like
that but yeah in terms of his characters
there's a lot of returning characters
returning faces that people the fans
have come to love and then there it just
brings to me such joy to see them again
like Dante and is
he's his lovable charm and and near I
was like really hot-headed
but infectious anger towards you know
wanting to prove himself I'm gonna go -
why don't you sit this one out
no let you call me deadweight again no
thanks I've got all the power I need
right here
you don't understand it's not what I
mean
the Ark's that they go through are
compelling enough there's enough of like
an emotional heart there for you to
latch on to despite it not being like
really incredibly nuanced or complex
right kind of like the the characters
are what really like propelled a
narrative yeah forward perfect timing
now we're starting act like a team ooh
you like flirting with me knock it off
get in the car
God so there's a lot of fanservice in
this game most of its pretty excellent
but there is a little bit of it that I
would describe as maybe even lame yeah
there's a lot of cool moments but you
know like was it like characters like
Trish and Lady who returned our you know
it's really awesome for them to be there
despite not really having much to
contribute to the story they bring
really nice sense of camaraderie to the
events there because of course you know
like yeah they're demon hunters there
did they be there there's just there's a
couple like nude scenes just come across
as kind of just like pandering just
fanservice pandering where like you know
normally like it guess they really
affected their depict their
characterizations because they just
don't do much like right it's cool that
they're there but they'd actually don't
even fight they don't really do like the
cool you know action set piece like cut
scenes that you've seen them do I've
seen them in and like in past games
they're really just there and so like
with how minimal their character is
their characterization is in this game
and just having this being really the
only thing that you know you see them as
it's just like come on man like there's
really nothing more that you want to do
with these characters you just want us
to kind of Google at them like that's it
like it just seems underutilized yeah
appreciate is it's it's egregious man
like and it stands in such stark
contrast to Niko who's a freakin delight
I love her she's this really fun
character who's just really strong
willed intelligent and is really the
reason why Nero's even able to kick so
much ass anyway because at this devil
breaker she she made them
building that wealth function in our to
keep demonex the other thing that you
mentioned is sort of underutilized was
the Cameo system which is this game's
multiplayer yes it's kind of a new thing
for the series if you want to talk more
about that yeah so each mission you know
as we said it's like a nonlinear
narrative so you know each character
sometimes characters are doing stuff
simultaneously and so like when you do a
mission one mission like you might see
another character going going past like
past you are doing stuff off in the
distance and this is fun like that when
you see someone off in distance it's
usually like an actual player playing
online or they're just their ghost data
right which I think you know adds like a
nice sense of sort of solidarity to the
events cuz like you know there's a coach
their sense of cohesion there I'm just
like oh yeah they're of course yeah this
character is doing something like that
like a little jump acknowledging like
their existence okay hey buddy
but like there's really only one moment
where that system really kind of is cool
I don't spoil it but like other than
that moment like it's incredibly
underutilized like you kind of wish it
had more to contribute to it you know
anyone in like seis not well put
together but it's actually kind of cool
that it exists but it's just like just
the air right it doesn't really affect
you one way or another okay
so we got a couple questions from
Twitter people wanted to know about the
game and it wanted to know they said DMC
five looks great but besides DMC the
reboot which they said they enjoyed a
lot I've never played the other games I
own them all is it worth going through
them first or I'd be fine jumping in
here and maybe going back later so I
guess that kind of brings up the idea of
a newcomer coming to this storied series
now like is it easy for them to jump in
yeah it's incredibly easy from the jump
in the story I'd say is pretty
accessible but you know if it's it one
thing I've learned from the past trying
to like get really caught up on a series
it's that like if you try to start with
the old games there's gonna be a part of
you that cannot stop thinking about the
new one so just play the new one play
the new one and then
use that as sort of a jumping-off point
to kind of go back to the past see like
oh this is what they were doing here you
know if you want to like really get into
the sort of the fan serving woman's just
like the fun like callbacks and stuff
then the least I could do is probably
Slyke look at like like a YouTube let's
play of just some of the character
moments that's it there is a like a
story summary in the the main menu which
does run you down on things so that's
actually a good tool not to refer to you
so the game makes it pretty easy to jump
right into it and then our other
question from Eman the great asks about
replay value
I think that's gonna definitely cry
always kind of encourages you to play
again
would you like this game does a good job
like making you want to like keep
playing after yeah no there's there's a
lot of reason to to jump back into the
game
that's it's it's not like any new
content per se it's just difficult
different difficulty levels that change
like enemy placement in any on all the
missions across the across the game I'd
say there's a but time to replay value
for that alone because the fact that the
game constantly introduces new bikini
mechanics even like well into late into
the game so by the time you're done with
it like you instantly want to jump into
higher difficulty levels so you can
experiment and start like and keep like
mastering and like refining your skills
with all the new tools that are
available to you so for me I've spent a
significant chunk of time in the the
higher difficulty levels so there's a
butts on a replay value as as we all do
that man well awesome it sounds like
definitely cry 5 is a fantastic game as
we said you gave it a 9 out of 10 superb
out of 10 superb out of 10 so yeah if
you want to check out Matt's full review
you can go check that out with Ron
gamespot.com and for all things duffle
make cry stay tuned to game spot
you